journalism is under attack
like never before gets fired
because people are doubting everything
you're the only way of
telling their story how would you
describe this outbreak something like an
apocalypse you're gonna be
really tired you're gonna be really
scared it's too dangerous
anyone who says they're not scared is
life anything
can happen did you get here i sometimes
wonder how have we managed to get out of
this
people we do genuinely believe in what
we do he's clearly marching press
to show the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover
an injustice this is the result of
ethnic cleansing
i don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford i'm stuart ramsey and this is
hot spots
yes
i think a lot of the neighboring gulf
states will be watching with some
concern
that this people power doesn't take hold
in their nations too
basically an unstoppable wave toppling
dictators of authoritarian leaders all
over the shop
wars peaceful revolutions violent
revolutions growing revolutions
i'd covered the gulf war i'd covered
lots of
military activity but there was nothing
like the arab spring
everything else was like a rehearsal it
was so many different places
so sort of chaotic at times but 2011 was
nothing like anything before
so here they come it was a very
exhausting
but fulfilling year that year probably
changed everything
it changed world politics it changed
the landscape it certainly changed
[Music]
me
[Music]
there was an incredible wave of optimism
which stemmed from tunisia
which was resolved very quickly and then
moved on
to egypt and this
wave of people everywhere you know in
alexandria in
cairo all over the place it felt like
you couldn't hold them back
egypt is an interesting one i remember
arriving there and it was quite clear
that the
usual arrivals in that country had
changed there were army everywhere
then you start getting to places like
tahir square and you can hear the noise
from a distance
[Music]
surely the barracks untouchable
the secret service are absolutely
everywhere you can't film in the street
without being stopped
it was the growth of course of social
media and that's how they were getting
their messages out and it was a real
part of the revolution it was a
revolution in its own right
the secret service was extremely good
but it wasn't built for social media
didn't know anything about it
there was a sense of hope that they
would bring about change there was also
a sense of determination
and actually if they had to die doing it
they would get prepared to die doing it
i was quite staggered by that
and i think what we found with the
revolutions that took place
that the only way they stood a chance of
succeeding
was when the population reached a point
that they didn't
mind dying attempting to achieve it
because there was no point
carrying on anymore
egypt was a lot different
[Applause]
it quite quickly got ugly
they were firing into the air at crowds
who'd come to attack us
the mob believed we as westerners were
supporting the president they want
removed
well that all really came out of nowhere
and the army is still
sitting outside the hotel with an
armored personnel
carrier the hotel now have said that we
are a security risk
being in the hotel they think the hotel
is going to be attacked
and we've been asked to leave
[Music]
[Applause]
we got up very early and joined the
promo barrack march
they were heading for turkey square
quite soon on it became clear this was
going to be a massive
moment
they actually took it over literally
walked straight into the square
the revolutionary groups were completely
taken by surprise
and within minutes the sort of the
whistle went out and the revolutionaries
started
gathering in big numbers and it turned
into this enormous fight
what started as really quite a friendly
meeting of the two sides
okay let's go for it rock throwing
coming from all sides
but now the promo barrett people are
pushing back again towards the tanks
they've been pushed beyond it we've seen
stones coming
the anti-mubarak people are calling on
reinforcements to come up
and man barricades that they've put next
to the tanks
from nowhere suddenly the crowd parted
camels and horses came charging out and
into the
anti-mubarak crowd i've never seen
anything like this in a riot before
horses crashed to the ground and the mob
moved in
the riders kicked and beat
[Music]
everyone could see these pictures but
from tv and from above
nobody needed to go run over by a camel
doing it though and kev nearly did
it was very frightening because the
rocks started piling in and so we found
ourselves in the direct firing line
kevin i got split he did an amazing job
of filming
some of the best work anyone did that
day was on the ground
the president muhammad mubarak decided
to step down from being the president
suddenly i just heard this enormous
noise
and the da that is it
i think i did alive straight away
because he'd come on the television and
he had stood down
uh we can see flares in the crowd that
are being waved around
every time there's an explosion from the
fireworks there's a huge
roar from the crowd really really quite
uh remarkable and
all the time thousands and thousands
more people are filing their way into
the squares but the noise was remarkable
that was absolutely staggering
absolutely incredible
i think what happened in egypt was
seismic and it also
was like um you know setting fire to a
touch paper
in in the arab world because they
thought if that can happen in egypt
there's hope everywhere
but the way it was going in 2011 stories
didn't really come to an end well just
another one started
this is a group of lawyers but they're
also teachers hospital staff
students and business people this is a
demonstration that's coming across all
sections of society
we tried to go straight to libya
from egypt we were told we were going
the next day i got a frantic phone call
from my wife
and my father-in-law died
it was so crazy work i actually thought
of not going
home crazy right and kev and neville
carried on and went into libya and i
came home
it's very easy to lose perspective and
then you can sort of very easily forget
what's going on in the real world
because you are suspended from being in
reality anymore
and sometimes you need to to really stop
and not go down that route but it's very
easy to say it
some somebody else needs to say it you
know sometimes
i suppose qadhafi is known as a
terrorist sponsor
he was an international renowned figure
another you know pretty cool in his day
you know when he was young he was
handsome
he he was a soldier he led about brought
about the revolution
uh he then had become very dictatorial
in the way he did things
pretty brutal but he'd been a sort of
hate figure pretty much my whole life
what happened in libya set the tone of
world events for
decades
we landed in tripoli when the regime
were very much trying to control what
the media did what the media said and
where they went
and when we arrived we didn't check in
with any of the government minders
and we we jumped into a taxi and said
take us to zowhere
[Music]
we saw this huge crowd coming towards us
we could see that they were waving rebel
flags
so we joined them and there was just
this big big mass of people
and they were heading towards a part of
the town
where they knew there were some qadhafi
soldiers on the perimeter
and as we got closer the qadhafi
soldiers just opened fire
[Applause]
people were falling all over the place
having been shot
give up look at these people
the vast bulk of the fire was coming
from the qadhafi side
it was the first visual evidence of
gaddafi
turning his guns on his own civilians
the bulk of whom were unarmed gaddafi
said he don't kill the people yes you
see that
at that moment i think we were most
concerned about being overwhelmed by
this huge
amount of people all racing to get out
of the area because they were all
terrified and then this ambulance came
by
to pick up some of the wounded
so we jumped in the ambulance and
within a few minutes we'd arrived at the
hospital
and then the doors of the ambulance
opened you know it's like
wow
shouting screaming
[Music]
that was what it was like for the next
four days
you can't shoot people when they are
facing you but this is the guy who was
shook in the back and when we were in
there we made contact with
this one doctor who was libyan but had
moved to canada but come back for a
holiday and we almost instantly
connected with him
dr m kind of adopted us
i hope so he decided that we were
the only journalist in there and we were
like
a protected species that needed to be
looked after
you know up until then i'd not
experienced anything like that
it was terrifying absolutely terrifying
and thing is that was just the start
dr m felt we needed to be taken
somewhere else
rather than stay in the hospital so he
took us to
a building where the rebels had set up
their command center
and next morning dr m
came and woke us and he said we need to
go
because the gaddafi tanks are on their
way
i rang the news desk and said these
qadhafi tanks are heading towards the
town
and they said can you get out and i said
no one can get out
never mind us
the fire is all coming from this
building so the return file will be
to this building we thought there's
we don't want to stay here in this
building because this is the
rebel command center and if they're
going to go anywhere it's going to be
here
dr m said i think we'll be safe in the
mosque because
surely they won't bomb the mosque where
is the mosque
it's right
we here out of the um the van that we
were in
and it was already mayhem
they were already setting up a sort of
triage area
and there were injured people coming in
all the time
[Music]
the doctors were panicking wildly
because they couldn't save half these
people
they had nothing to patch all these
injuries up with
there were bullets flying in and pinging
off the
the rebels courtyard armed themselves
because they've got a number of
protections from the army
but they appear to be unable to stop
them advancing and they are getting
closer and closer
i mean even the one injured soldier they
brought in was from the camas brigade
it was the most feared brigade and
suddenly they got one of the injured
soldiers in with them
so everyone thought we haven't got a
chance here
[Music]
people were praying around us they were
crying praying
saying their last rights you know saying
goodbye to
everyone
we really thought that we were trapped
there
and we weren't sure we were going to get
out
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
felt like we're in there for a lifetime
they were wandering out with their heads
in their hands going oh my god oh my god
and i walked out and there was there
were dead
bodies all over the place
i'm just walking out into the square now
and there are bodies of
some of gaddafi's soldiers lying on the
ground
suddenly people came pouring out of the
mosque their houses going oh my god
they've gone they've gone
coming under attack again there's
obviously a sniper
in a building somewhere who's
dr m scooped us all up and uh said
quick we've got to get to the hospital
because he he realized that
if they'd withdrawn they were going to
come back because there's no way that
these this ragtag bunch of civilians
could have repelled
gadhafi's army
we headed straight to the hospital and
we realized there were
qadhafi people still all around
the ambulance got shot at on the way
back to the hospital
and then we we stayed in the hospital
whilst we worked out how to get out
we were in tunisia at the time i think
we were trying to organize a a rescue
for them
from on a sat phone now as i remember
yeah
being very tearful when it when i got
the call through saying they're out
because they were a lot of trouble
that whole experience
changed everything for me personally i
think it
you know when you sort of cross a line
that was definitely it in my life i
think
it was it was pretty
pretty raw you you
you obviously martin and tim and i
[Music]
went through a very traumatic experience
then and because we went through it
together
we all you you all understand what the
other person's gone through
within the past hour the leaders of the
country's enforcing the un no-fly zone
confirmed they're taking what they
called
immediate military action against
colonel gaddafi's regime
what happened to zawir was a kind of
turning point because
days after nato
voted and declared a a no-fly
zone and that really signaled
the beginning of the end there was still
a long way to go
when i finally caught up with them i was
on
what would be the the tripoli side of
things well you're staying in the
rickshaws hotel which
is an amazingly high-end five-star hotel
i i did not want to be in that hotel
because that's not what i like doing
you still went and did quite cool things
i would go i went to gaddafi's
tent in babolation and and see him
holding core
and i'll remember that for the rest of
time well maybe this is a show by ken
gaddafi
to the other african union leaders about
how popular he is of course
this is his compound and the people who
are on the other side have been
busting they're here pretty much daily
because
he wishes to show he's popular not only
to his people but about the
international community as well
you know you go on a rubbish trip so
there would be greeted by
adoring qadhafi supporters all dressed
in green it's just ridiculous and it
became really really annoying
well even by recent standards this is
fairly limp stuff
i remember once i had split myself away
from the official group
i think i might have actually just gone
to the loo i came around and i could see
the little green men they're all sitting
around
um smoking sharing chris and being paid
money
sure enough the other reporters came
around because the tour had finished and
they all got up and they were all
chatting and screaming other things
it's just nonsense and we try to file
the stories saying this is an absolute
joke and try to make them as actually as
amusing as possible
well that is the case with all these
trips even to roman remains
the gaddafi renter mob is brought out
now in fact only two minutes ago
these guys were sitting at the car park
having a cigarette you'd hardly describe
this
as spontaneous support for colonel
gaddafi
quite often i would get a letter stuck
under my door saying you're israeli
we're going to kill you in the morning
and i used to write a return
return to sender [ __ ] off every night
thinking bumping never thought for a
minute they were going to kill me
obviously aware of the facts but don't
really want to talk about it the more
stories i did that annoyed them the more
they seemed intrigued and trying to keep
me there it was quite weird
but if you are filming the absolute
propaganda you have to make it
absolutely clear that it is
the sort of impromptu crowd of people
who have come to express her support i
believe
so i remember being taken out into the
countryside
the army is using civilian cars to move
its men a convoy
of brand new saloons was filled with
soldiers
they're also camouflaging their weaponry
from air attacks gun
mounted pickup trucks escorting a lorry
its cargo covered in hay
what he was doing was moving his tanks
around the country to keep him away from
the bombardments
pretending to be farming trucks covered
in straw
the dumb who ran his administration and
his br
had taken us right to the place where he
was moving his tanks around
one thing to remember when you're doing
dictatorships and dictators their
ability to
screw up is really quite staggering and
it was a good story
cause i went mad absolutely mad got
another letter through
definitely you're dead in the morning
because in the background it wasn't very
amusing and it was moving and moving
more and more closely towards a proper
war
and that's why alex's piece has been so
amazing from to where which of course i
tried to stop happening again people
have been skeptical to what alex had
said that happened did happen
and i wanted to go back and actually go
and revisit some of those places
well you can still see the signs of
damage that have been caused to
buildings in the center of the where
they were hit with
artillery mortar and tank rounds there
has however been a huge clear-up
operation here
perhaps the most remarkable thing though
is that i'm now standing what was
the main mosque into where it's been
completely raised to the ground
now hundreds of people huddled inside
while the fighting took place
outside we'll probably never know how
many people
actually died in the city
i remember going to the hospital where i
knew she'd been
where those people had died when they'd
been held off really scared
and i remember walking around and
speaking to
some of the nurses and i said do you
remember a girl do you remember alex
they would say yeah yeah no we do and
and i said well i'm a friend of hers
and what's going on now and all the rest
of it they were quite quickly
quiet judge can i ask you can i ask you
something
clearly there's something that's going
on here you can't actually get to the
doctors who were working when this
hospital had to deal with so many
casualties
the regime had really reinserted its
authority upon all shut up one can't
help but think that they've been told
they're not allowed to speak and
certainly for the whole of this trip
there have been minders
watching what they're saying and
stopping them and stepping in between
the cameras and reporters
and i think that's what we took away
this has been a hotbed of
anti-government uh feeling and yet he's
very quiet and basically
ultimately the regime had just smashed
it up
i was ready to return my worst fear was
that
somehow we wouldn't get in misrata was
like the second city
in libya and they refused to give in
to the regime it had been under siege
for a long time
the only way that anyone could get in
was via the port which the rebels held
we managed to get on one of the boats
and we were the only people on it apart
from the
small medical crew and we arrived in the
port
they loaded the port full of injured
people
and instead of going back with the boat
we decided we needed to stay in misrata
what was happening it was incredible
there was a full civilian army
mobilization all of these people were
previously doctors engineers members of
society
they work day and night here mending
fixing
adapting even before they finished
enjoying their latest battlefield
victory they know gaddafi's men
will return the significance of misrata
was that
everyone realized by this stage it was
not going to be over soon
and they had to dig in and prepare for
what might be a long
battle
it was clear that qadhafi was not going
to roll over
[Music]
in fact he was digging in if anything
so it was beginning to dawn on them that
this was
pretty much a fight to the death
an explosion of fireworks over zawir's
central square
it's a change from the tank rounds that
smashed into these buildings just a few
months ago
snuffing out the uprising here now
it's host to a pro-government rally with
thousands of supporters
chanting for the leader given the level
of opposition to colonel gaddafi in the
past amount of destruction the amount of
fighting that took place here
it's simply beggars belief that there's
been a collective decision by the people
of this town
to forgive kurt gaddafi in fact the
rebels tell us that they're preparing to
attack once again
and take to wear back you had to sort of
like live through it
and um and and then rotate you would
probably try and get away go on holiday
or something like that
i went on holiday that's a family
holiday bear in mind you know for the
kids haven't probably seen me for
haven't seen their father about four
months i remember ringing foreigners
said
i'm on holiday and i'm going to go back
that was that's the moment
and i wasn't in country i said they've
lost the road to tunisia that means they
can't get any supplies
it's over
[Music]
when we landed in zawir it was an
entirely different picture
we were standing round street corners
and they were
they just organized themselves now
the the rebels say that they have taken
control of 80
of zoe but clearly there is still a bit
of fighting to be done
when they finally took over zawiyah the
center was it was like a
is a battlefield of real excitement for
the people of
they've taken an awful long time to get
their uh their town back
and now the plan is to push further on
up this road
and head on into the capital
within hours they've taken jedem the
next town on from zarya and a step
closer to the capital they were
galloping along
they were very very confident at this
point i remember one of them saying
we're going to get to tripoli by tonight
and we just
looked at each other and thought i don't
think so
they are running like ruts so we are
doing very good job now
they pushed on again coming within 1500
metres of the 27th gate the western
doorway to tripoli
and then the qadhafi forces hit back
they are being attacked by snipers
who've been left behind
by uh the qadhafi forces and they're
just trying to
take shelter and smoke them out
but even as the qadhafi regime was
calling for negotiations and a ceasefire
the rebels were setting off again
they never expected tripoli to be easy
but the foot soldiers can smell victory
now
and they're in no mood for talking and
everyone was just jumping on saying
we're heading to tripoli come on we're
heading to tripoli
and um so we we jumped on the back of
this this pickup truck
there's a big traffic jam so andy
who is the producer said i think we
could try and get a signal because we're
going so slowly
if we powered it using the cigarette
lighter we can get the began up which is
this laptop
size transmitter which can beam pictures
to
london and the world and that's what he
did well i'm on
one of the rebel soldiers uh pickup
trucks and we're
still traveling through tripoli with
absolutely no sign of any resistance
[Music]
the pictures were pretty poor quality
but they were clear enough to show
that there was hundreds and hundreds of
people and they were all celebrating
can you hear the sound that's the sound
of people
celebrating november the 5th
times 100 they are going nuts
[Music]
and then when we arrived in what was
then
green square
it was just unbelievable
this was their signal to the world and
to get gaddafi that
he wasn't in control anymore because the
people had just taken over the rebels
had just taken over
well they are going absolutely crazy in
the central
i had no concept of how the world was
reacting
i was being fed back messages from the
news desk who were telling me things
like
the white house is showing your pictures
and downing streets just
commented on the fact that they're in
green square
we had no idea you know we had we were
just broadcasting what was in front of
us
my best friend has just stuffed the
world and i got absolutely nothing to do
with it
yeah didn't feel great but i was very
proud of her i was very happy
um i'd just like to have been there
[Music]
i got in and just headed straight
at times the city is utterly chaotic
this is green square they are
celebrating but in truth
they haven't won yet everything changed
very quickly
within the next 12 hours because
the qadhafi's weren't going to give up
that easily
it had not been easy
they never expected it to be but with
the colonel's son
safe insisting the qadhafis were still
in control and going nowhere
the opposition fighters took the battle
to his front door
there was furious fighting going on the
compound was heavily fortified
and we heard they'd managed to breach
one end of it
we headed straight to the sort of iconic
golden fist holding a jet and
we immediately set up live the
producer at the other end said stewart's
there as well
and it was like where is he well this is
a constantly changing front line
episodes you're going to hear the huge
amount of fighting taking place
just a few uh meters in front of us we
got to babylonia to the compound was
falling
alex had got him but we were around and
finally got
an entrance to get in and literally like
didn't know what day the week it was
hello good evening this is sky news at
six live from libya with the breaking
news tonight
that rebel forces have taken control of
colonel gaddafi's compound actually
there let's go straight to alex crawford
who's live there by that statue alex
hi we are inside the gadhafi compound
the emblematic uh hand crunching the
american apache helicopter the places
filled with opposition fighters and
soldiers i could hear
the producer speaking to
to alex then he spoke to me i was saying
uh there's a great atmosphere and there
are people streaming in and going out as
well there have been injuries and alex
was mentioning them we've seen a number
at least one person was dead that i saw
a number of other injuries as well
but people have been coming in and the
worry for senior officers is that they
have been taking away
huge numbers of weapons they gave up
trying to stop them they did it and in
the middle of this
this guy comes walking out of the the
smoke
wearing this crazy
colonel gaddafi hat
it was really pretty hard i i just went
inside his room
which is his bedroom yeah get off
bedroom
and i it was uh it wasn't really i was
like oh my god i'm
i'm in gaddafi's world oh my god
it was dangerous so um i was quite happy
just to get the life done and out the
way and then the two teams met
up at our life point they walked out
everyone hugged and we walked off from
just chatting about everything crazy
they go on
i remember stuart said it's not over you
know
there's going to be an awful lot going
to happen
the rebels have overrun an entire
qadhafi encampment
leaving behind a trail of dead qadhafi
soldiers and mercenaries
you could see that a number of these
qadhafi soldiers
had been shot in cold blood because they
had their arms tied up
and that was the first indication that
the rebels
were committing atrocities and war
crimes but at that stage no one
really wanted to hear that they still
wanted to see it very much as a
civil uprising that had toppled a
dictator
the traffic islands here are still
strewn with dead bodies
bodies which are quickly rotting in this
fierce heat
we were just thinking oh god we've got
to get out we've got to get some rest
alex's team needed to go they'd been
there a while never exhausted and we
we carried on there was a call from the
boss
and he he was talking and saying i i
really don't think you
realize the impact your reports have had
and we had absolutely no idea
tripoli changed suddenly to be not yay
it's all over
the revolution to no this is now
actually
we've gone into war mode now it was
absolutely crazy
the clearance operation is happening but
there's a lot to do
so it was a sort of chaotic sense of
we've taken over we're winning and
continuous fighting taking place
but the rebels are about to attack the
base that belongs to the
camis brigade now this is the second
largest military
institution after babylonia i think it's
going to be quite a fight here they seem
determined but there's apparently a lot
of qadhafi
soldiers still inside
there's some amazing footages of the
leaving and going ahead
and then suddenly reversing at great
speed and just bullets coming at us
there's one picture that you can see i'm
on the other side of the road from our
crew
but you will actually see me just
running up the street i'm
almost going as fast as a truck
now i remember running that run with
bullets going between my legs as i was
coming
thinking this is it and i was just
sprinting sprinting
and then they'd regroup themselves and
go heading back
that took a couple of days this
continuous on and off
story was trying to find qadhafi we knew
that he'd been in that camp
he'd been there with one of his
daughters and they had headed off in
what we believed was the direction of
cert
and when we were there one of the
fighters said
you should see something
we came to this sort of barn and it was
full of bodies
that have been set on fire
[Music]
it is a scene of mass murder
[Music]
you can see what is basically a burnt
out warehouse but that is full
of executed people 53
bodies we've counted them
i remember speaking to foreign desk and
saying
we've been talking about this i think
we've actually found it now i think that
this is actual
proper war crime here
it was a very important story because
that was
absolute proof if you needed it that
this regime
was prepared to do pretty much anything
especially as it was falling apart
so we were very proud of that story
because it had not been seen before
and in a day or so it was covered
worldwide
the rebels believe that this car
belonged to camas gaddafi
it's certainly an armored vehicle we can
tell that they think
that he was part of the convoy heading
south about 50 trucks we're told we know
that some of them at least were attacked
by nato disappears have been attacked by
a jet or by a helicopter as well it's
top of the range car for certain it's
got communications in the back
which would suggest that it is being
driven or driven for
a very important person we had to assume
that at least one of the sons was now
dead
and it was just all adding to this
really quite complex tapestry of exactly
what happened because ultimately
everyone was trying to find
so this house here yeah definitely
qadhafi was definitely in this house
colonel gaddafi is dead killed in a
clash with revolutionary fighters
as he tried to flee his hometown of cert
and the video came out i think he was
caught
basically like in a culvert or in a
little [ __ ] and then was
nastily executed
the killing of gaddafi was so brutal
and it was so raw it was hard not to be
shocked by that
it's almost certainly the most macabre
tourist spectacle in the world
and it's designed by the misrata brigade
to prove that colonel gaddafi is dead
that was ultimately the end of my
involvement in the arab string uprising
in libya
finding a daffy dead there were three
bodies inside
of basically a massive fridge and people
were just being asked to file by and we
were allowed to go in and film
it felt very strange it's a difficult
thing to film actually
because you know you could you have to
show it but it's a bit yeah how graphic
can you be well the international
community will be fairly appalled that
this is taking place
people cueing to pass little gaddafi and
his sons bodies
they wanted people to see that he was
dead because that was i mean this was
done
on purpose you know the revolution is
has won
there was a lot of desire for revenge
it was a foreshadow of some awful
dark moments for libya that were going
to stretch out ahead
the rebels were no longer heroes
and whilst everyone was focused on libya
this sort of
really important oil-rich country
they weren't watching what was going on
in parallel
in syria the world got taught a big
lesson
by what happened in libya
and so did other leaders so
bashar al-assad was watching with
horror what had happened to colonel
gaddafi and
learning from it i think bashar al-assad
thought
what's happened to gaddafi that's
definitely not going to happen to me
there's this whole sense of fear because
the syrian army is not very far away
they have been moving through villages
and clearing them out clearing the
people away
pushing them towards the turkish border
and many haven't crossed over those
thousands have we believe about a
thousand a day are currently
uh crossing over
in the last few minutes or so we've
heard the sound of gunfire in the
military probably only about two or
three kilometers away from here
this is the front line if you like if
rebel held territory but as you can see
this checkpoint certainly not going to
stop the military if they decide to
advance up this mountain
we finally get to homs which is a big
city
and we were taken up to the center of
the revolution if you like
free syrian army were there in very
small numbers had a few guns between
this is very much the front line snipers
are all pretty much around here
you see the amount of pop marks there
are in the walls from incoming rounds
it's
fairly continuous this is really the
stronghold if you like
uh for the resistance to the syrian army
but there is a concerted assault on them
there's not really much they could do
[Music]
we were taken on a number of occasions
to
go to everyone who gathered night after
night after night
in alleyways or streets that they could
protect so that the snipers from the
government couldn't shoot them and they
would sing
revolutionary songs
these were not jihadists these were
students doctors
mothers children and they wanted a vote
they weren't even asking for regime
change
they were asking for elections
[Music]
i remember us going there it became the
piece
of big piece that we did and one of the
best pieces i've probably ever done
and it was the daily life in holmes it's
just after breakfast time
they're buying bread and preparing for
the day ahead
welcome to hot
it's like this every day
[Music]
there's one shot of a boy and he's
running back to get back to his house
he drops his bread
and he's like oh no no no is he going to
get shot
he goes back you know you know he's like
you see kids playing with a football
outside and the ball goes into the road
don't run after the ball
the arab spring has turned to winter but
in syria people are still dying
for wanting freedom that is all
and there's an amazing shot actually but
we never used the picture
we didn't use the picture but i've seen
the picture again
but uh they came out with all their
banners and it says thank you sky news
the guy who's carrying it was dead about
three days late
i remember when things went really bad
and they got attacked i remember them
saying
do you think we could ring up bashar and
tell him we were joking
and uh everyone laughed there was like
it was no fun
we thought it couldn't get crazier than
libya
it did in syria plus some
it was like libya on steroids
it was the start of a story that
dominated my life for a very long time
and in effect
it's been dominating a lot of our lives
for a very long time
all the people smuggling all the deaths
all the suffering that's still going on
now it all
stems from what happened in the arab
spring
yeah and it
probably defined what i would go on to
do for the next
decade
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a body of work that i'm very
proud of
anyone who covered anything in 2011 at
the extreme levels that
some sky people did and me and addicts
definitely did
will have learned from those we'll never
forget
you can't be seeing all of that living
through all of that without it
leaving scars
now it's like the world is
almost unshockable in some ways i think
it probably set me up to cope with a
load of other things that
i didn't know were going to happen
further down the line definitely did
in the short term i was broken
really broken we want to have a guy and
we die in our
country i wouldn't give it back to
anyone i loved it
but it was hard no doubt about it
2011 should have been the year that
changed the middle east forever
i don't believe it did in the end
[Music]
it was a real period of optimism
bizarrely despite all the suffering and
the trauma
but actually it went on to get massively
massively worse and the whole of that
region
has been fractured and splintered and
restructured and is still fighting
[Music]
we'll still shake your windows
you